[Music]
crystal's in greensboro north carolina
hey crystal what's up
hi it's a pleasure to speak with you all
you too how can we help
so i have a question it's probably a
common sense question
but i have a situation
my car is currently in my ex-husband's
name as well as my name
and i'm unable to renew my vehicle
registration
because he owes about eighteen hundred
dollars in personal property taxes on
his car
[Music]
i owe about um sixty seven hundred
on my car um but i i can't keep riding
around you know with expired tags
so um why do you have expired
if your name is on it why can you not
get tags
because his name is still attached to it
and whatever car is in his name
everything is put on hold
on oh so the personal property taxes
keep you from getting taxed yeah
exactly but how long as how old is the
divorce
uh we've been divorced for about six
years now so i should have been
gotten his name off the car yeah
what's the car worth uh
probably about 3 500. oh jeez yeah
yeah whole thing's not worth fighting
over it's not you have any money um
yeah i've got money saved but i'll
market food for a house
so how much um about eight grand
okay does he does he uh does he own
anything
does he own it does he have a car that's
worth two thousand dollars
um i'm not sure if his car is paid off
or not
does he have anything he could give you
that's worth two thousand dollars so you
can go and pay the eighteen hundred
no sir
well here's what's running through my
mind i'm bouncing these numbers back and
forth
okay 1800 versus 3500 that's not a play
i want to make
uh 1800 of his bills i don't want to pay
no
i don't like that play right um you owe
6 700 it's worth 3 500 is his name on
the loan
uh yes his name's still on the loan and
you have eight thousand dollars
um it's not a very good move
but off the top of my head i can't think
of another one uh tell the bank to come
get the car
do a voluntary repo
oh my goodness yeah that's going to mess
up your house
yeah yeah and i i need a car
yeah but if you pace if you pay this car
off at six thousand seven hundred
dollars
and it's worth three thousand and you
put another eighteen hundred in it
we're now approaching nine or ten
thousand dollars you have invested in
this car that's worth three thousand
five hundred because you can't get tags
on it and broke boy can't you can't get
any money out of him
i don't know how to get you out of this
you could spend uh money on an attorney
but suing a rock it's still a rock after
you sue it
you hit a rock with a hammer it never
bleeds
in other words you can sue his pants off
and he won't have any pants but he still
won't have any money
right soon somebody doesn't make them
have money you follow me
true now you i guess you could garnish
away his wages
you know and then get the stinking thing
but still you're going to owe
6 700 if you take the 8 000 you pay the
car
off it still doesn't get it out of his
name
exactly it takes nine thousand dollars
to get this car debt free and in your
name and it's worth three
yeah and i've um i can make an
appointment at the dmv
for us to you know go get it signed over
just to me but that's all the way in
december and i'm
impatient oh i didn't know you could do
that that's what you do yeah
yeah oh that's that's the best you
didn't i didn't know this was an option
that you said you couldn't do it i was
about to ask that question but the music
came on
i'm not a fan of her doing the repo day
that's why i don't like it either i'm
just trying to figure out how to get out
of it but i thought
as long as the dadgum 1800 standing out
she can't get a transfer
right but if she could take him in there
in december by the ear
and get it out of his name that's what
you do it was supposed to interrupt me
while i was making a mistake during that
last call
and didn't do it so uh the difference is
in some states
they're a personnel tax or personal
personal
effects tax or whatever affects a lien
on a vehicle
and our state it does not right so some
states it does some it does not
and so then if it does affect the lien
on the vehicle and was keeping her from
transferring the title
which you grew up there right so you
actually knew this and i'm sitting here
don't know what the crap i'm talking
about so you should have jumped in
but the um uh she has the ability to get
that
removed by going down to the dmv then
that's a much better suggestion all she
has to do than my dangerous
voluntary repo suggestion oh yeah i was
just i was just waiting for a great day
to come in there and uh just you know
take care of you but uh the music came
on so waiting for a pause
right right right but all she had to do
was just go down there
she long she has proof saying that she
is divorced um
she can go down and make an appointment
and immediately uh they will go in ahead
and take that off of her car and still
hold him liable for
his issues and his stuff um but i i
wasn't a huge fan of her doing the repo
because
he wasn't a fan of it either somehow
she's got to get
shed of this guy yeah six years later
yeah so um you know i'll tell you what
it does tell us um
i don't know her situation exactly but
it is a reminder
the things that you don't button up
in your life will come back and bite you
in the butt yeah when you don't have a
will
it's gonna mess up your family for
a year or two trying to get through the
mess that you leave behind
when you don't when you say okay i've
got a trust
but you never move the title of the
stuff into the trust
you never follow through on those
details yes
you're pledged according to a lawsuit to
do x or y
and you don't go do those things you
leave yourself
open to just get hammered later you do
and so there's a possibility i'm not
sure in her situation but there's a
possibility
this all should have occurred like the
day of the divorce
absolutely or within 30 days of the
divorce she should have gotten this done
a long time ago she should have got it
done ashley within the first 36 days of
their of divorce being official yeah
probably i don't know her whole story
but sometimes people get
uh sloppy okay finally the divorce is
over but i'm not gonna
worry about getting the beneficiary of
my okay my husband is my beneficiary on
my life insurance
but i'll get that changed later no get
it changed now you're gonna leave the
guy who's divorced rich when you die
right now go change that tomorrow yeah
i'm gonna change the beneficiary on my
401 k
now right you know i'm going to do that
quick claim deed on that house
now you know and so button the stuff up
man i'm not saying i'm not yelling at
her but i'm just saying
sometimes we go like i'm just out of
emotional energy for dealing with this
twerp yes
no i don't care shut up yeah throw your
shoulders back and finish yeah
get it done whatever it is i mean when
you leave your old
job and you're sick of that job roll
your 401k
over finish up do the details roll it
over to an ira
always finish the details there's
something about
wealthy people and it's not because they
worship money but they somehow
say i have to finish the details finish
the details and they know all the
details before they go into it dave and
she was married but let's talk about how
these single people
who are buying cars together and doing
stuff together like they're married
look at the situation that you could be
walking into in the future
that's why we say dude really nice
because what you just described is super
stupid
super stupid but people are doing it
that's just super stupid
they're doing it i'm buying a car with
my girlfriend yes
this is super stupid very very it's a
way to not have a girlfriend
nor car yes and you end up with neither
one and you got the bill too
yup this is super stupid yes it is
run around acting like you're married
because you what you are let me just
tell you from a legal standpoint you can
ask your lawyer because i'm not one
but you just created a general
partnership and there is no partnership
documents yep
what happens when your partner becomes
disabled come on disinterested yep has
drug use
uh just generally takes off yes
and disappears and you can't find them
yeah they call them a partner
yes in a relationship sense but let me
tell you from a legal standpoint you are
in a
general partnership with no partnership
documents
yes you do not have a way to exit the
partnership legally yes
and so because you entered this on
stupidity you're going to leave it on
stupidity yes and that situation would
have been much harder to get out of if
she was in
if they were in that exact same
situation as the last caller
because they don't have any paperwork
showing it that there's no divorce yeah
exactly
there's no end to that so now now we
have to go back to what you were
recommending oh so now my girlfriend
my boyfriend didn't pay his personal
taxes oh see what i'm saying
oh that's what i'm saying like we just
really got to make sure that the
dangers of shacking up come on the
dangers of acting like you're married
when you're not married
what the dangers of doing things
together yeah we want to buy a house
together no you don't
no you don't we want to buy a car
together no we don't no we don't
we want to get married together now
we're talking you see
yeah yeah absolutely you know you make
that decision it changes everything yes
but you know the number of times and
it's
some of the saddest stories i've had to
do with one-on-one coaching over the 30
years
but um it hasn't been that often but
it's happened enough
that it just scares the crud out of me
where
you're going along and you know they're
engaged
but they move in together and buy a
house together yeah and she gets killed
in a car wreck three weeks before the
wedding
guess what yeah he owns a house with her
mama yeah
because he's not her heir and there's no
will
oh or they put dump all their money in a
bank account
with both names on it and he put in a
hundred thousand and she put in five
thousand
before they're married and she gets
killed in a car wreck he has cancer and
dies
has gets helped by the milk truck
whatever the scenario is right yeah
or you know guess what you know her
father now her mama whoever her
air is her natural hair because there's
no will is now got access to half of
this guy's hundred grand
and i'm trying to go well uh
yeah this is what we call stupid tax
when you do something stupid and it
costs you
money and i have paid so much stupid tax
so it always breaks my heart when i'm
talking to somebody's got stupid texts
but it is stupid it causes it yeah and
you just lost money because you did
something stupid
so buying houses combining accounts
buying cars
you know all this you know running
around acting like you're married when
you're not
it's so freaking legally relationally
financially naive and stupid last year
dave i
uh did a one-on-one with a young couple
in their mid-20s
the young lady um called me and
she did a combined account with her
boyfriend
combined account with her boyfriend
she woke up one morning he's gone all
the money's out of the account
because they had combined accounts
and she said she filed a police report
she said the police officer said that
because you all joint the account
together absolutely
nothing he didn't do anything criminal
and i'm sitting there like
and i'm going to be like see i told you
do not do that he needs a butt weapon
right but it wasn't criminal
right oh my god so
that's what i'm just saying like just i
i pray i pray people hear us
well you know i don't i don't want you
to get caught though
and that guy was a straight-up con there
yes i mean he's
straight up gigolo i mean just sleeping
for money and there's cons out there
man there's unbelievable there's
even if they're not bad things happen in
some of these situations
and it's just like you know well i
looked up my old boyfriend on facebook
and said
you know we're not going to really do
this marriage thing after all and so
but he really wanted your car
but you know what though here's the
truth dave you said this and and i
believe this would be true
good people make bad decisions when they
are emotionally hurt
yeah hey i do and so i believe let me
tell you
the dumbest things i've ever done in my
life when i was desperate yes
or when i was embarrassed yes yes are
those kinds of things and those are
emotions they aren't anything else
yes right before i lost lose money it's
usually desperate or stupid
or desperate's right before stupid yes
embarrassed is right before stupid i get
mad it's right before stupid yup you
know these are the things that cause you
to lose your butt on stuff
because you're not thinking and you're
not treating this
like a transaction because by the way
it's a transaction
oh my gosh
there's a little fodder for your next
anthony o'neil rant on youtube i could
do that one
y'all see it next week here we go here
upcoming attractions